what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's looking like Marvel Studios is
not only about to make one big
announcement but it looks like they are
about to make several big announcements
and it looks like they're going to be
coming pretty soon and I know a lot of
us have been wondering about the
Fantastic Four who's going to be playing
these iconic characters for the first
time in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
well it looks like we might not have to
wait too much longer to know the actual
cast this is only one of the
announcements that Marvel could be
making pretty soon and what's
interesting is overall right now it
seems like Disney is kind of shifting
their strategy a little bit when it
comes to streaming so specifically
talking about Disney plus and other
streaming services that they own like
Hulu it looks like we could see a big
change coming for this very soon and an
announcement about this soon as well
according to a report by bloomberg.com
they state that Walt Disney Co is
exploring the sale of more of its films
and television series to rival me media
Outlets as pressure grows to curb the
losses in its TV streaming business last
year in the third quarter Disney
reported a 1.5 billion dollar loss for
its online video business this is where
Disney fired Bob chapek and then brought
back Bob Iger and based off of this we
knew that some changes might be coming
to Marvel Studios Bob chapek was simply
pushing out content he was trying to get
as much content out on Disney plus as he
could however Bob Iger seems to be
different he values quality over
quantity and due to this fact we might
actually be experiencing a delay with
Marvel's Phase 5 and phase six and this
is something that we knew might be
coming and is something that isn't all
that bad because it means that they're
going to focus more on making their
projects better and having more time to
do that now Bob Iger will report the
company's financials on February 8th
that's five days from now so we might be
getting some type of an announcement for
any type of delays in Marvel studios's
phase five and six then if there going
to tell us about a different structure
in Disney plus as in making less TV
shows but more that are better quality
this is probably when we're going to
find out so stay tuned be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of those
videos now as far as the Fantastic Four
are concerned like I mentioned there
could be a very big announcement about
that pretty soon and with that might
actually come the announcement of the
villain who is apparently going to be
Galactus now we've talked about this a
few times but some insiders have hinted
at this even more yesterday The Insider
account on Twitter can we get some toast
simply tweeted hehehe with the eyes
emoji but if you go to this account you
can notice that the background header
for the Twitter account is now changed
to Galactus and some are stating that
this could be very early concept art of
Galactus so this could somewhat be a
little bit of a first look here now it
looks like typical Galactus which is
awesome Galactus is an iconic character
from Marvel Comics plus not to mention
animated series and just in general an
iconic villain so I'm assuming Marvel
Studios is going to keep his classic
look the same unlike what fox did
basically turning him into a giant
thunderstorm so it looks like the
classic look is what we're going to get
thankfully but replying to that tweet
was The Insider my time to shine hello
she has been very accurate with her
Scoops in the past and she replied
simply with the Fantastic Four logo
telling us that it seems like some
Fantastic Four News could be coming soon
now this is coming at the same time that
many insiders are reporting who they
think they know the new Reed Richards is
it looks like our Mr Fantastic could be
Dev Patel and this is being reported by
multiple different sources phantomwire
tweeted I don't need sleep I need
answers what do you think about it and
they should read Richards next to Dev
Patel and then they hashtagged read
Richards def Patel the Green Knight
Fantastic Four then on top of this tweet
my time to shine hello retweeted this
and said he's in in the mix for sure and
recently somebody posted some leaks
anonymously online that a lot of people
are believing are true in those leaks
this person stated that Marvel Studios
is looking at a person of color to play
Reed Richards so this does line up with
that report however the reports of Dev
Patel playing Reed Richards have not
stopped yet according to Lizzie Hill the
editor-in-chief of the cosmic circus and
Alex B of the cosmic circus as well they
have heard the same thing and Lizzy
tweeted here's hoping that death Patel
will be read though I don't know for
sure Alex from the cosmic circus and I
heard he was a top Contender from a
friend a few weeks ago then on top of
that Jack mcbrian the founder of the MCU
direct replied to that with yep backing
up the rumor that Dev Patel is the top
Contender for Mr Fantastic so many
different sources here are stating Dev
Patel is at the top and since we have
some reliable insiders stating that some
news about the Fantastic Fours coming
probably pretty soon it looks like we're
about to receive some news and what
what's really interesting is that Grace
Randolph has reported a couple of days
ago she hears that Century casting news
will be any day now so it seems like
clearly Disney and Marvel Studios are
really focused on casting right now
casting of course for the Fantastic Four
casting for the Thunderbolts and Century
which by the way right now if you
haven't heard I think the top contestant
for Century who's going to play him is
Ryan Gosling now we've talked about this
a little bit before in a prior video but
I think he would actually do a very good
job he's got scale as an actor and we
know that he can get in Crazy ripped
shape in fact he probably still is right
now from filming Barbie he got in really
good shape to play Ken and I'm assuming
he's still kind of in the same shape now
we're not sure if we're going to get the
entire cast of The Fantastic Four or if
we are just going to be receiving who is
playing Mr Fantastic it is totally
possible that Marvel Studios wanted to
cast Reed Richards first then from there
cast actors who kind of go well with him
now of course they always have multiple
people in mind for one role so they
could have several people who they want
to play Sue storm Johnny Storm and Ben
Grimm but they could just simply be
waiting to get their Mr Fantastic and
then go back to those people and choose
who would fit best and look best with
them on screen of course you have to
have Good Chemistry Between the actors
if you have bad chemistry the audience
can usually tell the movie usually isn't
that good and since we are casting a
family Marvel's first family who is
probably going to be on screen together
for the next 10 to 15 years in the MCU
you definitely have to make sure that
they have chemistry but at least we can
hope to get some news about Reed
Richards very soon now as far as
Galactus is concerned him being a
villain for the Fantastic Four to me
makes perfect sense he's an iconic
Fantastic Four villain plus we've had
reports that we are getting a Silver
Surfer special presentation before the
Fantastic Four movie and the arrival of
the Silver Surfer typically means
Galactus is coming so the Silver Surfer
special presentation will set up
Galactus arrival in the Fantastic Four
now as far as who could play Galactus at
this point in time we're really unsure
if it's simply just going to be the
voice of an actor for Galactus or if
it's going to be that actor's actual
face a couple of names that have been
thrown out there that we talked about
the other day are Dennis Quaid and Keanu
Reeves now I personally love Keanu
Reeves and think he would make a great
Galactus I would love to hear his voice
play Galactus however a lot of you
pointed out in the comments section that
you would love to see Keanu play Ghost
Rider and I have to agree I think he is
my top choice for Ghost Rider I think
that would be perfect for him so I don't
want to say I'm rooting against Keanu
playing Galactus because I will
definitely be happy if that happens but
I would like to see him play Ghost Rider
now as far as when we can expect to hear
all of this news Well if there's any
changes or delays to Marvel studios's
Phase 5 6 and Beyond I think that might
come this February 8th that's when
Disney has their financial reports but
as far as the official casting goes we
are most likely going to figure this out
from insiders and then whatever next big
event that Marvel Studios has that's
when they'll announce it officially so
basically subscribe to the channel and
hit that notification Bell if you want
to stay up to date on the latest casting
news if we hear anything at all we'll be
sure to do a video about it and report
it to you so leave your thoughts down
below about Dev Patel possibly playing
Mr Fantastic and let us know if you have
any good ideas for casting choices of
your own don't forget to like the video
and subscribe and for live updates you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof